i love meeting rvffs from all over the
country i mean this is how we're doing
it in 2020 this is our new solve until
we get back to
a studio audience but i have to say i
think this is so great because
we get to really open it up you know
instead of people just in new york we
get to be with people from
all over our amazing nation and
i also love eating food from all over
the place that's right
so that's why i'm excited to have a
brand new segment where we're finding
out which regional dishes
reign supreme it's time for battle of
the bite
chicago pizza
[Music]
oh
we all know we all know deep dish pizza
is a windy city fave
and today we're gonna try slices from
all
three chicago restaurants that are some
of the favorites in the city
all right and we have a very coveted
award
the battle of the bites trophy it's
right over there
[Music]
by the way we did a trophy also for like
best costumes i'm telling you
these awards they're really attractive
i'm just saying i need a pizza partner
in crime though to help me
judge so welcome back to the show our
co-pilot for the week the
emmy winning ross matthews
let me tell you how excited i am about
pizza today i woke up with a real spring
in my step
i play last night i had a salad for
dinner because i knew we're doing pizza
today let me
i got salad for dinner tonight but i'm
going in on this pizza
you know what that reminds me i need to
take like six digestive enzymes
so young um have you ever had
they work the things you say drew
it's all about good digestion i only
know that after i treated my body like a
garbage truck for my entire life
now it's got to be a holy place of
worship um
have you ever had real chicago deep dish
chicago is one of my favorite cities and
if you go to chicago and don't get deep
dish you didn't go to chicago
right can i get an amen on that so yes i
have and that's why i know what is
waiting in front of me right now
see i have been to chicago many times
but i always am like i'm one of those
foodies who looks like
on the eater list eater is my favorite
website
ever eater if anyone knows eater it's
it's it's
a holy place and i try to go to like the
best new sandwich shop or this like
restaurant that you know
got a rave review recently and i haven't
had
real authentic chicago deep dish pizza
what today is the day drew today is the
day
that i'm gonna do it and we have three
slices in front of us
one from lou malnati's one from gino's
east
and one from labriola and people are
very passionate about these pizza places
yeah
and they're deep dish yes that's why
we're lucky enough to work with them
because they are like
top tier and guess what we also sent
three slices
to our vffs and they can taste and be
virtual judges
marissa kenny
and marjon
[Music]
guys oh and this is a fun fact our sixth
judge today with
us you guys is going to be twitter great
we put a poll out asking you to vote on
your favorite slice and then we're going
to count that
as one of our votes and determine the
winner as well okay is everyone ready
why am i wasting so much time yes by the
way this is like the closest i've gotten
to a dinner party in almost a year
right look at this by the way i love
this is what we dreamed about with this
wall you should see behind there it
looks like ai it looks like a steven
spielberg movie
it's like okay what order are you doing
fork and knife
i am hello yeah oh wait oh god
they just said in my ear go to the tape
first go to the tape first
sorry my first slice cuts from blue
malnottis
can you tell i'm eager
hi drew i'm mark malnati from
illuminati's pizzeria in chicago
in 1971 my parents opened a little
pizzeria
and we had lines out the door around the
corner down the block
last year we shipped over two million
pizzas we have a
beautiful dough it's flaky it's buttery
others have criticized it for being too
thick too bready but this is a meal in
chicago
there's almost three quarters of a pound
of mozzarella and
half a pound of sausage next we're going
to pile on
whole peeled pear tomatoes from
california we finish it blend a romano
parmesan
few herbs you've got buttery flaky
creamy salty garlicky and sweet
tang of tomatoes drew we'd love to send
some to you so let's see what it looks
like
coming out right to you i'm guaranteeing
that we will take home the gold
my mouth is watering all right let's do
this ready everybody here we go
oh my god i can't even oh my god i'm not
even speaking
raj thoughts i'm
i'm thank you
yes yeah yes yep
yep yep yep it is so like bright tomato
tomatoey acidic
cheesy the crust is yummy yeah it's so
cheesy it's like i feel like i'm eating
cheese rather than
cheese on bread yeah and i'm fine with
it turns out
marissa you've never had a deep dish
before what are your thoughts
i haven't had one before but oh my gosh
the tomatoes taste like they were just
picked off the vine and this crust is
delicious i'm gonna have some more
what a great critique by the way like
fresh off the vine
china okay so good next
okay we're gonna do gino's east um take
a look
hi drew thanks so much for having us
we're so excited to be here my name is
jordan himmel and i'm from the original
geno's east of chicago
gino z started in chicago in 1966.
since then we've taken every step we can
to preserve the way we've always made
our pizza
we sustainably source our ingredients
and we take quality
to the utmost importance what's unique
about our pizza
is that we have this delicious golden
flaky crust
we're very excited to be uh honored on
your show
enough chit chat let's eat some pizza
shall we
oh yeah that looks delicious to me
i'm gonna sit here and enjoy this slice
i hope you enjoy yours
thank you all right let's try it
everybody here we go guys
she knows east
oh very different so different way
herbier
i'm going to say orega no okay i know
you did
regular you did honey what do you think
you know this has the visual of what i
think of when i think of a deep dish
pizza
the ratio it's a lot of dough but the
ratio is still good between the cheese
the dough
and the sauce i agree and you're a deep
dish fan
none of your friends like deep dish but
you've also never tried these three
particular places right
that's correct anytime i have deep dish
no one else wants it so i end up eating
the entire thing by myself and then
regretting it later
oh i feel you there we have one more
place to test and um we've already tried
lou malnati's
gino's east and and gina and kenny
did those and now we're gonna go to
labriola chicago take a look
hey drew rachel abriola here from
labriola chicago
we've been making deep dish for uh four
years right now
we set out to have the best pizza in
chicago and that was the goal
and we achieved the goal through many
hours of trial and error
to get a pizza that is unlike any other
we're doing 1500 pizzas a week at this
time
so on our deep dish the most important
part because i'm a baker
is the dough and our dough is similar to
a focaccia dough
there's 48 hour fermentation and another
24 hours once it hits the restaurant so
that's optimal for flavor
always whole milk mozzarella always
finished with grated pecorino
romano we also add a little bit of
italian calabrian chiles to our sauce
our deep dish pizza is actually very
light and flavorful and those are the
elements for a great deep dish pizza
drew our pizza is unbeatable
and once you taste it i think you'll see
why
oh bring it can we eat it yet
all right let's do this ready oh i've
got aluminum foil hold on
already i'll notice the cheese goes all
the way to the crust which i appreciate
this crush is incredible marshawn
you're like me right you've never had
like an authentic
chicago deep dish right absolutely true
that's this right here
and i'm not even a cheese pizza person
but this right here makes it seem like
eating a whole bunch of ingredients and
one
cheese is phenomenal and the crust
homemade
i've only had like numero uno you know
i'm from california in the 80s you're
like this is chicago deep dish and by
the way it's great
i always loved it but this is really
such a fun experience like
marissa kenny and marjan i'm so excited
that i've gotten to do this with you
and of course ross but it is the moment
of truth it is time for us to vote
but before we start let's see who won
the twitter poll first okay
oh yeah that's interesting who ready
it's uh oh
lou malnati's what won the twitter poll
big time like by a landslide
all right now let's see um one at a time
we're gonna reveal
our favorite guys are you ready marissa
kenny marjan
i'm taking this way too seriously right
i know
okay okay okay ready yeah
you're gonna go yeah i'm going
it was the carissa what you got
flag labriola the crust ross knows where
it's at
thank you thank you kenny
oh everybody's oh my god well you know
what to each his own wait okay so that's
three
okay illuminati
it was a close one but i gotta go
illuminati's luminati's okay
and okay margin is luma naughty's all
right so i'm
the odd man out with jesus gino says
here's the good news
everybody gets the love on this show no
one feels bad and i like that
because i don't like that in life when
people make people feel bad
yeah so good every restaurant got love
but the winning restaurant is
[Applause]
lumonady
there you go i i will say i did love the
labriola crust
the crust for me but i have to say i
really love gino's east and i'll tell
you why because i love the
herbaceousness
herbaceousness is our word of the day
thank you drew
congratulations to everyone
i'm at work right now and i just want to
say
that nothing has been as fun as this
look at our jobs today you guys come on
we are so lucky thank you for doing this
with us
and i just want to say also
that i'm really grateful to gold belly
they're one of my favorite companies
literally because you can order from
restaurants that you love
all across the country yes and stuff
in your mouth like this you too could
eat while you work
talk while you eat and enjoy
something very extraordinary and special
how many times have we said oh if i
could
only have the clam chowder from legal
seafoods in boston
just yesterday no no not really
my sister-in-law joel cardman sent me
some through gold belly so
thank you gold belly that's how they
made this happen
thank you to everyone i can order deep
dish pizza to my house from chicago from
gold belly amazing i'm doing it i love
you gold belly
and marissa and kenny and marjan rossi
ross
thank you so much